streaming your data down to your own
local environment can be slow and costly
in this episode of AI adventures we'll
see how to bring your notebook
environment to your data what's the only
thing better than an interactive Python
notebook interactive Python notebook
with fast and easy cloud connectivity of
course last episode we looked at just
how useful Jupiter notebooks are and if
you missed it I'm included a link in the
description below this time we'll see
how it can be taken even further by
running it in the cloud with lots of
extra goodies or run some analysis with
some powerful tools and even larger data
sets as you work with larger and larger
data sets in the cloud it starts
becoming more and more unwieldy to
interact with a using your local machine
it can get tough to download
statistically representative samples of
the data to test your code on and
streaming the data to do training
locally relies on having a stable
connection so what is the data
scientists to do well if you can't bring
your data to your compute bring your
compute to your data let's see how you
can run a notebook environment in the
cloud close to your data set Google
Cloud data lab is built on top of the
familiar Jupiter notebook with some
added abilities including easy
authentication with bigquery datasets
fast operations to Google Cloud storage
and sequel query support let's go create
a data lab notebook and get set up for
running our notebook in a cloud install
the data lab component using G cloud
components installed data lab then we'll
have a new command-line tool called data
la starting data lab is a one line
command this command spins up the
virtual machine that you'll use for your
analysis configures the network and
installs the necessary libraries that
we'll use including tensorflow pandas
numpy and more once data lab starts it
will open up a notebook environment that
looks pretty similar to what we saw in
jupiter notebooks however unlike before
this is a environment that's running on
a virtual machine in the cloud data lab
installs some samples by default which
makes a great
place to start exploring let's take a
look at the hello world notebook which
is in the docs folder here we can start
playing with the notebook right away
running cells and experimenting this is
super convenient since there was no need
to deal with managing different Python
libraries and configuring them let's
take a look at a few additional tools
that are built in let's will click on
the account icon in the upper right
corner and take a look at all the
options and information that we're
presented with here first
note that the notebook is running as a
service account the service account is
already authenticated with the assets of
the project that we are in but if we
want to access resources from another
project we'll need to grant access to
this service account not the user
account since the virtual machine that
the notebook is running on is accessible
to anyone who can access the project we
don't want to expose our own account
credentials in the data lab notebook now
as we continue on downward we see that
this data lab notebook is hosted on a
virtual machine on Google compute engine
and the virtual machine is called AI
adventures and we can shut down the VM
by clicking this button here now by
default data lab has a feature that will
shut down your virtual machine once it's
been idle for about 30 minutes and you
can toggle this feature by clicking the
message to disable and re-enable it this
timeout can also be set to a custom
value let's go over the settings to see
how we can do that the value we set here
will remain in place across reboots and
of the virtual machine and if you've set
it to zero auto shutdown will not occur
so this is just another way to toggle it
off basically and additionally you can
also select a theme of light or dark so
if you're feeling like you want the
screen to be dark or we can stick with a
light theme keeping it Airy now we have
our data lab notebook setup and we've
gotten familiar
environment so let's see what can
actually do with data lab today I'm
going to run through an example that
describes the correlation between
programming languages used on github
that is if you program in language a how
likely are you to also program in
language be the notebook is in the
samples directory under the docs that we
are in right now and I've also placed a
link in front to github directly in the
video description this notebook uses
numpy and pandas to analyze bigquery
data and visualize it using that plot
lip so naturally the first step is to
import those libraries the table that
we'll be pulling from is the github
timeline table and that lives in the
public data set samples provided on
bigquery let's see what the table schema
looks like notice that we can use this %
% BQ to ax end operations to bigquery
without needing to do any additional
scripting authentication or deal with
the rest API response well there
certainly is a lot of columns and we can
also see how many rows there are as soon
as I get past all of the columns okay
so if we run this query here we can pull
the number of rows from the metadata and
we see we have about 6.2 million rows
and we can also use the sampling feature
from bigquery and that'll pull rows
directly from the table into data lab
but it's a smaller chunk of data so you
don't need to query the whole table
which would otherwise take a while and
allows us to easily see the format of
data and do some sanity checking so we
can see here we just pulled five sample
rows and the you know all the different
columns associated with that so we just
pulled these four columns so it's really
just a slice of data now let's go
onwards to the core of our analysis
these are the queries that will run to
grab the github commit data and the
languages associated with them notice
again that we're using this beak
q or % % BQ magic and this time to
create our sequel Cray will actually be
able to write sequel directly and you
notice here that we get syntax
highlighting and it all is indirectly in
the cell rather than having to wrap it
in the string of an API call now these
cells create the query but it doesn't
execute them yet to execute them will
actually just call execute and you'll
notice here we have popular languages
and that was the name that we called our
first query your name popular languages
and so that's where we construct the
query and here we execute the query and
looking at the results we see that
JavaScript Java and Ruby are some of the
largest number of pushes well at the
bottom we see that our MATLAB and puppet
have the fewest number of pushes in this
sample data set will also execute one of
the other queries that we had and put
down the number of and see the number of
Portia's by user ok anyone see
themselves on this list perhaps yeah
let's let's load our query results now
into a panda's data frame doesn't get
easier than this we just call two data
frame now we can use all our pandas
analysis skills on this new data frame
so we can see that we have the data load
and a data frame and we can use that
described here we can see some
interesting stats including who has
contributed to the most number of
distinct languages looks like someone's
actually had contributions in nine
different languages pretty impressive
now we will need to actually further
shape our data toward our end goal of
correlating languages with each other
specifically if we want to have columns
for each of the 25 different languages
we need to have the rows be the user
names and the columns be 25 across so a
pianist actually has a handy function to
help us do this it's called pivot
and so we'll use that to create our 25
by wide table here with all of our users
and this is gonna have a lot of zeros
because even the most ambitious user as
we saw only has nine different languages
pushed to now we can take this and
compute the correlation between the
different columns for each possible
language pair so 25 by 25 basically and
we'll do that using the core function so
we'll get that correlation so and you'll
notice that we have core here at the
bottom so it prints it out and so now we
have our 25 by 25 table
unfortunately this table of decimals is
no fun to look at and it's hard to
really tease out any trends here so
we'll use matplotlib to make a more
colourful plot so that we can more
easily see where the notable
correlations lie so once we have that we
can see we'll run that and Wow
that's a that's a lot of colors I would
see here that the strong of the blue the
more positively correlated the two
languages are and the stronger the red
the more negatively correlated the given
language pair there are some interesting
language pairs that are notable here
first you see that Java doesn't really
mix well with a couple of different
languages you know here's our Java and
we see that it doesn't like so much to
doesn't show up much with JavaScript or
PHP or Ruby and C and C++ on the other
hand do seem to go together very well
not super surprising there and
CoffeeScript and JavaScript also get in
that blue box to be combined together
looking kind of broadly at the data set
I also noticed that Ruby and PHP both
seem to have a lot of read some of them
quite read across their rows this makes
me wonder if one of these languages
could get the prize which one would get
the prize of least likely to go with
another language perhaps something we
can analyze another time
so this analysis used only a small
sample of the larger github public data
set and if you want to work with the
full github commit history I've included
a link to that public data set down
below as well data lab is a great way to
run cloud connected notebooks close to
your data with convenient connectors to
tools like bigquery with easy
authentication to your data sets in the
cloud thanks for watching this episode
of cloudy I adventures these shortest
subscribe to the channel so you can
catch all the future episodes right when
they come out for now go and try out
data lab and see if it's the right
choice for your data set